right here are the two strains that are
going on in politics today in in the US
and in Europe one strain is is is from
people who say look we're all now
multi-faith societies so to desing to
say we're Christian countries is
actually to somewhat diminish or demean
people of a different faith this is one
strand mm-hmm the second strang are
people who see a kind of assertiveness
from particularly from Islam frankly
from around the world and they start to
react against this and say look you know
I'm a Christian I'm proud of it so
what's your problem right type of thing
you can actually see that in in European
politics now I mean the last few
elections in Europe underneath the
surface that is the argument that's
going on it it pops up in immigration
maybe but really underneath it's a
cultural issue to do with people's
concern about whether their society is
being altered and they they are somehow
you know kind of like they feel right
we're a kind of host nation but suddenly
the guests are taken over the house a
bit and what's going on with that right
now how do you make sense of that and I
mean one way of making sense of it is is
what Nick has just said so you say look
we are a Christian people but this state
is religiously neutral another way of
doing it because we have this debate
over the European Constitution where
there was a move to say to refer in the
Constitution for Europe that we were
developing to refer to our
judeo-christian heritage now in the end
the French subjected to that for very
kind of French reason school which is
which is basically to say look we have
the revolution about all that and we're
not sticking
sticking anything in there about it so
but so that was that that in the end
sort of took care of the problem in a
way rather fortunately because otherwise
there was quite a disagreement between
people who tended to say look we have a
judeo-christian heritage so why can't we
say that and others who said look if you
say that you're sending a signal say to
two Muslims within Europe that you're
not really fully part of the family so I
think you're conflicted views are very
very typical and I think the only way
you make sense of it in the end is to
say we are proud of our traditions and
if we are predominantly a Christian
nation we are proud of our as Christians
were proud of our faith but when it
comes to the sphere of the state itself
then that is something where we are all
equal irrespective of our religion now
we're about to have an we're about
actually to have in the context the
Middle East peace process an actual real
life example of this dilemma because the
Israeli government are now saying we
want to designate Israel as a Jewish
state now by that they do not actually
mean since twenty percent of the Israeli
population are practicing Muslims they
do not actually mean that you've got to
be Jewish in order to be an Israeli but
exactly that conflict is happening so
some people and some people who are
Jewish within Israel saying if you do
this you are effectively getting rid of
something that's very intrinsic to our
state because actually we work we are on
a jury state whereas we're a state of
Israelis right so this is this is right
at the heart of this cultural question
that's that's going around everywhere
and I think the only way to make sense
ferd is isn't a sin sin to take the sort
of type of structure that Nix Nix
outline which is why the academic nature
of what we're trying to do in this
course is important because you need in
the end to try and make sense
some of this and the only way of making
sense of it is to say that you you know
is to make sure that in a sense people
in America don't feel they're denying
their heritage your people in Europe
don't feel they're denying their
heritage at the same time as making it
absolutely clear that in front of the
courts when it comes to the vote when it
comes to your voice we are completely
equal now these are difficult things to
do one of the reasons why the Interfaith
notion is so important in my view is
that that is one of the things that can
help cure that what is almost an
emotional conflict within people about
their identity